kristen it is so nice to see you again
this was truly an oscar-worthy
performance it was so incredible to
watch you in this congratulations um
who's the one person you were most
excited to see your portrayal of diana
oh wow that's a good question nobody's
asked me that yet yay
[Music]
uh
hmm
oh god i don't know everyone
i'm so i have
um a couple of friends that i hadn't
seen in a minute and they after the
premiere wanted to come to dinner
because i've seen it a couple times now
and and while the screening was
happening i went to go eat sort of wait
for everyone to watch the movie yeah and
they wanted to hang out with me and i
was like you go watch that movie right
now
i was like no you can hang out with me
whenever
um oh man i wish i had a better answer
for your singular question
yeah that is
different wanting to share it um in the
way that i want to share it like i'm
usually not such a champion for projects
that i'm a part of i think he made such
a weird movie about something so
beautiful it's it shocks me um and it's
in its sort of unique way yeah and i'm
not just trying to promote my movie i
genuinely feel this way about this movie
but yeah everyone
yeah no apps it's beautifully haunting
um can you empathize with what diana
went through in terms of media scrutiny
um i mean i i don't think it's any
small thing that we are
starting to to acknowledge the
differences that we treat
men versus
women in the media yeah um
and
you know this is a movie that definitely
confronts that head-on and i think that
she was somebody who also spoke really
articulately articulately about that
yeah um
and so it's nice to be a kind of
continuation of some of the
conversations that she started
and uh
i myself i'm so lucky my job as an actor
is um about leaning into attention and
kind of opening up and
yeah
kind of enjoying the opportunity to
reveal yourself and
knowing that i can always kind of grow
and make mistakes and change really does
change the experience i think that
you know i'm not a princess that is such
a different vocation she was she was
expected to
perpetuate something that for her felt
really dishonest and ultimately
not uh not something that she could
sustain it wasn't even worth living that
way it was like literally going to
and i don't mean to sound like
overdramatic but like
it was going to kill her like she needed
to get out of there yeah um and she did
really triumphantly and that is what our
story is about the movie is is about
liberation and it's kind of a jailbreak
movie and yeah
um it ends on a high note because she
she did accomplish her goals i mean she
really became in the last few years of
her life so embodied and present and
honest and
on the forefront of her causes and
um yeah so in the last five minutes
you kind of contend with this triumph
and then also the ultimate tragedy which
is implied but not
you know you're not sort of drug through
the mud in this way but um
yeah at the end of the movie you
understand that she was
i just think her whole life kind of
washes over you even though we only deal
with three days of her life
absolutely
prince harry and prince william are
characters in this film uh if they watch
the film what do you hope they take away
from it
um
i mean this is a person that i mean her
her
her legacy is walking and talking and
her boys and i think that yeah
are
you know
incredibly positive influences in
in different directions
but ones that do feel quite honest and
real and relatable which obviously the
royal family has never
quite been allowed to do and i i just
think that she
she represents such positive
and and progressive change in the world
that uh i would say we led with love and
curiosity and absolutely never
tried to add to the pile of opinions
our movie definitely asked questions and
sort of like dreams to imagine what it
might have felt like before she made
this decision which i think impacted the
world so beautifully so
um
i also you know will just like weigh in
on this and say that from my perspective
which is
only mine
she loved art and i think this whole
thing that she kick-started everyone
being so sort of so addicted to this
story and like trying to figure out what
we may have gotten from her if we had
her for a little bit longer yeah only
keeps her alive um
so i guess all of that who knows and
maybe nothing you know what i mean it
really was just sort of uh
a genuinely curious and and um
you know endeavor that came from a i
don't know a loving place
yeah thank you kristen you're incredible
congratulations thank you appreciate it
you